proposer en réponse aux quelques
demandes qui m'ont été adressées
évidemment avant notre échange
d'articuler cette introduction en deux
grandes parties d'abord vous dire
quelques mots de notre transformation et
de la manière dont nous avons traversé
les circonstances graves nées de la
crise du coc vie 19 et ensuite
évidemment partager avec vous quelques
réflexions plus large sur les mutations
et l'avenir de la grande distribution un
exercice prospectif d'autant plus
important qu'il intervient au coeur
d'une année qui est celle espérons le
bien sûr de la sortie de crise d'abord
peut-être quelques faits et chiffres sur
le groupe carrefour on a l'impression
que vous l'avez dit nous sommes un des
leaders mondiaux de la grande
distribution nous opérons à 13000
magasins sur trois continents 30 pays
neuf filiales intégrées et un chiffre
d'affaires de près de 80 milliards
d'euros en 2020 deuxième caractéristique
nous sommes pour autant profondément
ancrée en france où nous sommes nés il
ya 60 ans à annecy au croisement de deux
rues et c'est ce croisement de deux rues
qui conduit à notre appellation
carrefour carrefour france et 45 % de
novembre ces cent mille collaborateurs
vous l'avez dit c'est un modèle qui
associe tous les formats de magasins
c'est une des spécificités de notre
groupe
des hypermarchés et des supermarchés de
la proximité du cash and carry du disque
monde du bio et tous les modes de
gestion on y reviendra peut-être
intégrés et franchisés location-gérance
une des spécificités de notre modèle
c'est que nous avons l'intégralité des
formats et l'intégralité des modes de
gestion
j'ai noté que vous aviez
quelques-unes de mes questions mais je
suis sûr que mes collègues vont y
revenir et s'il n'y reviennent pas j'y
reviendrai vous me le permettez
alors je vais passer la parole pour
commencer au président de la délégation
aux entreprises et auteur du rapport sur
l'évolution du commerce serge babary
ensuite anne marché merci madame la
présidente monsieur le président
directeur général bonjour je tout
d'abord merci évidemment de ses propos
liminaires qui éclaire dans toutes les
directions économique l'action de votre
goût et son succès dans une terrienne
évidemment difficile sur le plan
sanitaire et que le miel concernant
évidemment les nouvelles formes de
commerce ou les avait évoqué on a bien
entendu
l'accélération que la crise avait donné
à ces nouvelles formes de commerce et en
particulier votre adaptation à l'omni
canalité termes que vous employez
également et qui est celui qui décrit
les nouvelles formes mises en place pour
répondre
finalement à l'attendre des
consommateurs parce que au centre de
tout ça est l'objectif principal c'est
de satisfaire le consommateur donc il ya
un certain nombre d'attentes des
consommateurs en termes de qualité des
produits vous l'avais dit en termes de
prix bien sûr en termes de sens à leurs
achats en termes de recherche
d'adaptation d'application de circuits
vertueux en terme d'environnement
tout cela doit être pris en
considération dans l' architecture que
vous êtes en train de modifier et qui
est un chantier évidemment considérable
écoute
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner
quelques
éclairage sur l'évolution des nouvelles
formes de à gaza depuis l' hyper qui est
l'aboutissement d'une longue évolution
de vos deux outils de distribution
quelle en est la situation maintenant et
à partir de là les nouvelles formes
jusqu'à jusqu'au retour en centre-ville
finalement j'allais dire le carrefour
initiale que vous avez cités tout à
l'heure avec des magasins qui ont une
autre forme de distribution et qui
s'adapte parallèlement à ça et c'est
notre souci du moment d'ailleurs avec le
projet de loi contre le dérèglement
climatique c'est celui de la logistique
qui s'appuie sur la distribution dès
qu'on modifie les sorties de
distribution dès qu'on modifie les
formes de commerce il faut adapter les
circuits logistiques
on est tenté de compans qu'il faut
réduire évidemment et le souci du
dernier kilomètre en fait partie le
transport vous y répondre et en partie
avec le kilomètre zéro pour les achats
d'une partie finalement minimes de vos
approvisionnements mais c'est un sujet
d'importance pour les collectivités
locales qui doivent s'implanter souvent
à la proximité des villes maintenant des
entrepôts intermédiaires qui se chargent
l'éclatement dans les plus petites
surfaces que réimplante les uns et les
autres dans les centres villes mon
deuxième sujet c'est un élément
d'actualité qui
l'initiative de votre part du jour
quasiment qui rejoint aussi notre
réflexion dans le projet de loi sur le
dérèglement climatique c'est le test sur
les prospectus dématérialisée alors vous
vous lavez lancé ces jours-ci dans dans
deux hypermarchés à lille et à soyaux
les chiffres sont impressionnants
puisque vous nous imaginez pouvoir
éviter évidemment le gaspillage inutile
en économisant 300 tonnes de papier à
lille et 260 tonnes à soyaux en
proposant à vos clients de choisir sur
le catalogue papier ou digital qui
pourrait recevoir par les différents
canaux habituels
est ce que vous pourriez nous dire un
mot de cette initiative qui évidemment
est une petite révolution dans l'
approche marketing
merci monsieur le président merci vous
c'est un peu plus compliqué mais voilà
une salle archi ensuite rémy cardon
merci madame la présidente merci
monsieur le président pour votre votre
propos extrêmement rassurant et je
voudrais saluer la gestion que vos
magasins entendu insufflé par part
votre politique que vos magasins ont
fait de cette crise une gestion vraiment
admirable tant humaines que qualitative
humaine bien sûr vis-à-vis de vos
personnels j'ai pu le constater
dans mon coin de seine-et-marne humaine
vis-à-vis aussi de votre clientèle qui
étaient rassurés à l'idée de venir faire
les courses dans vos magasins et
qualitative aussi parce que comme vous
ne l'avez dit vous avez développé et
vous et allez dans le sens d'une demande
de mode de de consommation qui apparaît
et qui est plus que nécessaire
alors à ce sujet je voudrais vous poser
deux questions même si vous y avez
répondu partiellement d'une part
la dimension humaine de vos magasins qui
viennent dans les ramifications rural
notamment des magasins de proximité des
carrefour market city ou express comptez
vous les développer est ce que c'est une
pérennisation qui s'annonce chaud au
contraire peut-être une réponse à une
demande liée à la crise et ce que vous
continuez à les développer et d'autres
par contre concernant le la part
qualitative de votre politique
avez vous une estimation de la part des
produits vendus aujourd'hui dans vos
magasins en circuit court bien entendu
et qui proviennent d'agriculteurs locaux
avez vous des objectifs chiffrés visant
à augmenter cette part en valeur et en
volume
je vous remercie monsieur le président
merci anne rémy cardon suite rock mais
non villa
merci madame la présidente de mes chers
collègues monsieur bompard pour donner
suite au rapport de notre groupe de
travail agriculture et alimentation est
en lien avec les négociations sur la pac
j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur la
rémunère rémunération des agriculteurs
en effet sans cette politique agricole
commune aux agriculteurs ne pourrait pas
s'en sortir est d'ailleurs l'un d'entre
eux m'a expliqué son malaise puisqu'il
aimerait bien évidemment être rémunérés
grâce à son travail et non grâce aux
aides et cette situation est porteuse de
souffrance et risquent d'impacter de
nombreux agriculteurs français est
d'ailleurs chez cafo chez carrefour le
prix du lait est à 80 centimes le litre
mais combien et il a acheté aux
producteurs si on part du principe de
quelques éléments du rapport papin si on
paye alors juste valeur les producteurs
agricoles français les augmentations des
prix sont minimes
alors il ya le port le rapport prend
l'exemple de la boîte de haricots verts
en conserve qui est donc l'augmentation
serait autour de 4 centimes mais je vous
la corde ça dépend des produits mais ma
question est simple ces quelques l
engagement prend carrefour pour garantir
la souveraineté alimentaire pour notre
pays dans les années à venir
je vous remercie
merci madame la présidente monsieur
président donc vous êtes à la tête d'un
géant français et d'un géant mondial de
la grande distribution
vous aviez
vous êtes peut-être encore et vous étiez
en discussion avec le groupe canadien
couche-tard mac est ma première question
c'est peut-être vous puissiez évoqué les
synergies que vous comptiez vous comptez
donc établir avec ces deux groupes ces
complémentarités
la deuxième question qui en découlent et
peut-être aussi en lien avec la loi et
galim c'est que nous voyons depuis
depuis de ces dernières années notamment
accentuer peut-être par là la lm une
concentration des des centrales d'achat
des capacités de négociation donc delà
de la grande distribution qui
déséquilibrent les les contribué à
déséquilibrer les accords les relations
commerciales et qui a conduit à cette
loi et galim qui je pense nous pouvons
le dire est plutôt inefficiente pour ou
pas suffisamment efficace actuellement
est-ce que effectivement ce genre de 2,2
de regroupement n'est pas pas accentuer
cette ce déséquilibre
commercial comme ont donc rassuré
j'allais dire les maillons de
l'industrie agroalimentaire et des
producteurs qui aie qui s'inquiète sur
le sujet la deuxième question de la
troisième question c'est peut-être
votre avis sur le rapport papin et
notamment sur la contractualisation
écart contractualisation pluriannuelle
qui semble quand même donner de la
visibilité de la visibilité et des
perspectives donc aux différents acteurs
économiques producteurs et
transformateurs et l'atr la dernière la
dernière question était plutôt en lien
avec la crise sanitaire on alors vous
avez évoqué la digitalisation la
numérisation de du commerce
c'est un des premiers effets le deuxième
effet été j'ai à dire l'orientation de
nos concitoyens et des consommateurs sur
des plus tôt des cieux des surfaces de
proximité des magasins de proximité de
moyenne surface est plutôt une certaine
désaffection des très grosses surfaces
des hypers est-ce que c'est toujours le
cas aujourd'hui et quelle stratégie en
ont tiré ou voilà merci monsieur prévost
merci beaucoup
franck alain cadec ensuite que francis
oh oui monsieur le président directeur
général
merci d'abord madame la présidente c'est
vrai qu'on va tourner autour des mêmes
questions un petit peu agit toujours dit
que je serai il vaut mieux se répéter
que se contredire donc c'est vrai que la
première question assez par rapport à la
loi et légal iml a déjà été évoquée par
le président tout à l'heure et par les
collègues évidemment c'est quelque chose
qui nous interpelle qui est censé
favoriser réellement une meilleure prise
en compte des coûts de production et qui
manifestement tarde à produire ses
effets pourtant de nombreuses filières
ont mis en place des indices de coûts de
production validé par la commission à
bruxelles et qui manifestement sont
toujours pas utilisé alors quelle est la
position de carrefour est ce que
carrefour prend réellement en compte les
coûts de production dans la négociation
commerciale
oui ou non ces blanche et noire
pardonnez moi deuxième question qui a
déjà été évoqué pendant mon collègue
tout de suite mais qui nous interpelle
également
c'est évidemment l'épisode couche-tard
de couche tard qui nous interpelle
pourquoi parce que couche tard est un
groupe canadien manifestement très
solide qui est valorisé
aux alentours de 40 4 milliards d'euros
ou 20 40 camions de 44 milliards d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires valorisation de
valorisation parts de marché contre 80
pour vous d'ailleurs à peu près 80
milliards à sénologie d'affaires mais
voilà on est par contre en bourse
ils sont exactement beaucoup plus élevés
goût et ils ont fait une proposition
d'après ce que je sais de rachat à 20
euros l'action carrefour alors même
qu'elle est et côté aujourd'hui aux
alentours de 16 17 euros 17 ce matin
quand je suis là c'est ça va bien
aujourd'hui je gagne un peu d'argent
excuse moi j'aime bien le capitalisme
il a été moins qu'on soit il à fait
d'accord en tous les cas l'intervention
de notre bon ministre des finances vous
avez vous quitté leur d'ailleurs cela a
fait que ce ce rachat n'a pas pu se
faire
alors la question c'est qu'est ce que
vous pensez de l'intervention de l'état
et du gouvernement dans cette affaire et
de ce qu'on souhaiterait nous être une
vision stratégique sur les opérations de
fusions l'a vu récemment dans un autre
dossier et n'a rien à voir avec le vôtre
c'est le dossier veolia suez
l'opposition de l'état était extrêmement
ambiguë donc voilà ce que les deux
questions je voulais vous poser monsieur
le président directeur général merci
madame la présidente lui le président
directeur général j'aimerais directement
abordée avec vous au sujet l'agriculture
et le rôle que joue la grande
distribution dans la rémunération des
agriculteurs
en effet plus de deux ans après sa
promulgation le bilan de la loi galim
est particulièrement mauvais mais c'est
un échec reconnu unanimement par tous
producteurs consommateurs
l'objectif présidentiel de permettre aux
agriculteurs de vivre du juste prix payé
à paraît bien lointain et cette
situation malheureusement dramatique
dans de nombreux territoires ruraux
al'inverse il semblerait bien que les
industriels et la grande distribution
ont profité de cette loi pour élargir
leurs marges dans un rapport en date et
il a déjà été vu 25 mars dernier serge
papin a formulé neuf propositions pour
renforcer la mise en oeuvre de la loi et
galim ce qui me conduira sûrement à une
égale in 2 et parmi les propositions de
ce rapport on peut notamment retenir la
garantie d'un marche en avant du prix
notamment en rendant non négociable le
prix de matières premières d'un produit
à forte composante agricole ou encore
retenir l'idée de redonner de la valeur
à l'alimentation en renforçant
l'encadrement des promotions alors
ma question est très simple et directe
monsieur le président directeur général
face à ces propositions quels sont vos
réflexions
je voulais retrouver quand même très
timide dans votre propos liminaire
c'était une impasse et j'imagine
volontaire c'est la question parce que
je savais la présidente vous a posé à 6
ans très clairement aussi donc je me
permets d'insister et que porte
concrètement votre groupe pour améliorer
justement la valeur entre les acteurs de
la chaîne agroalimentaire et
particulièrement les agriculteurs je
vous remercie madame peut-être on va
commencer par couche tard parce que
celle là je les ai entendus le plusieurs
fois et puis mais vraiment interrogé
mois sur les petites questions je
pourrais çà et là à voir à avoir oublié
l'opération le l'opération couche tard
alors peut-être un mot liminaires et aux
eaux qui est qui qui est une résultante
au fond d'eux de la crise à la fois de
la crise d'épidémiologique et puis de la
crise sectorielle
on est dans une période et vous l'avez
vu dans d'autres secteurs d'activité
vingt d'entre vous a évoqué une autre
opération
on est dans une période où il ya une
une densité de deux projets d'intérêt d'
analyse de situation de rapprochement
partout dans le monde
vous le voyez je suis sûr
quotidiennement en ouvrant vos journaux
économiques
il ya une il ya une grande densité de
2,2 d'opérations envisager de
discussions préliminaires etc
c'est d'autant plus le cas quand vous
êtes dans un secteur qui est traversée
par des mutations extraordinaire où il
faut investir des milliards d'euros ou
des acteurs sont en difficulté ce qui
est notre cas
j'en viens maintenant à couche tard
d'abord est-ce que nous avons initié
cette opération
la réponse est non je dois à la vérité
de de vous dire que moi même je ne
connaissais pas et je m'en fais le
reproche
le groupe couche tard il y a un an à la
même époque
j'en avais entendu parler comme le nom
d'un grand groupe de stations service
qui avaient beaucoup ici mais je ne
connaissais pas donc je n'ai pas initié
cette opération et je l'est d'autant
moins initiés que je n'en ai pas besoin
le groupe carrefour se développe bien
vous l'avez compris à redresser la pente
connaît des résultats soutenus solide à
des plans de développement pour le futur
a fait des acquisitions dans plein de
géographie depuis 18 mois donc je
n'étais pas dans une situation où
j'étais où je suis encore moins
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs recherche d'une
opération de consolidation où je serai
moi-même consolidé donc je ne suis pas à
l'origine de l'opération
après la séquence a été très simple ces
camps sont toujours importantes pour
comprendre les opérations le groupe
couche tard qui est donc vous l'avez dit
monsieur le sénateur un groupe très
crédible qui partie d'une station
service a construit un groupe qui vaut
45 milliards de de capitalisation qui
est donc plus grand en capitalisation
que le premier groupe français qui est
au carrefour nous a approchés
à la toute fin et même au dernier jour
de l'année dernière pour après avoir
fait un très gros travail d analyse des
entreprises européennes pour nous
proposer un projet de rapprochement
entre les actifs de couche tard est le
groupe carrefour avec comme idée non pas
comme je les ai entendus par l'un
d'entre vous de d'exporter des produits
canadiens puisque dans une station
service et un magasin de proximité il ya
très très peu de produits ces instants
ciellement des stations essence et des
produits du quotidien des mêmes marques
nous vendons aujourd'hui c'est pas comme
si c'était un très grand groupe de
distribution canadienne avec des
produits agricoles qui serait exporté
vers la france on n'était pas du tout
dans ce cas de figure
leur idée est en étais je vais essayer
d'être leur porte parole ce qui passe
qui est peintre est logique mais je vais
faire l'exercice
il ya la place pour un leader mondial ce
leader mondial doit être présent sur
tous les continents vous êtes en europe
et en amérique latine
nous sommes en amérique du nord il ya la
nécessité de rapprocher et d'être un des
trois premiers tracteurs mondial avec
une réseau de magasins et un réseau
produits différenciés qu'est ce que vous
faites quand vous recevez dans la nuit
du 31 décembre au 1er janvier puisque
c'est exactement cette millar et
malheureusement c'est dans ces
opérations les faits sont têtus
quand vous recevez un appel puis un mail
pour vous dire que vous
quelqu'un souhaite et vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure avec un prix
articulé réfléchir à une opération de
rapprochement
eh bien vous l'examiner parce que c'est
votre responsabilité je n'aurais pas
joué mon rôle si je m'étais dit tout
seul dans mon coin dans la nuit du 31
décembre au 1er janvier
cette opération n'a aucun sens aucun
intérêt je la jette à la poubelle et je
ne regarde même pas puisque c'est un
groupe crédible qui proposait un projet
qui était travaillé avec une offre
financière qui était une offre
financière que nous devions considérer
pour l'ensemble de nos actionnaires
on a fait ça pendant quelques petites
journées très très courte et puis on est
revenu vers no no no no no no collègues
canadiens en leur disant pour entamer
des discussions
non pas pour se mettre d'accord pour
entamer les discussions
voilà les conditions qui nous paraît
être celle d'une ouverture de
discussions
il y en a un certain nombre qui tenait à
l'autonomie de fonctionnement du groupe
carrefour et d'autres qui tenait aux
garanties pour l'écosystème et pour les
parties prenantes de carrefour
l'autonomie du groupe carrefour
c'était qui dirigera le futur groupe il
est éteint et take votre serviteur y
joue évidemment un rôle central
quel est le collège des actionnaires
français quelle est leur combien ils
représentent dans l'ensemble où est ce
que le groupe est coté et donc la
question de la cotation à paris était un
élément essentiel que nous avons mis en
avant ou est ce que sera le siège social
etc
c'est à toutes ces questions qui sont
des questions dites de gouvernance et de
au fond de conduite des opérations
et puis ensuite il y avait une deuxième
partie de demandes pour ouvrir les
discussions
quel est le projet que vous avez quelles
sont les garanties que vous apportez à
l'emploi de nos collaborateurs quel est
le montant des investissements vous
voulez faire dans nos magasins français
et donc nous avons
vu pour la première fois notre confrère
canadien dans ce cadre de discussions
qui s'ouvrent en leur disant voilà les
conditions pour rire ils ont réfléchi
deux jours qui sont repartis au canada
et ils nous ont appelés pour nous dire
sur les basses que vous venez de nous
présenter ce qui ne préjuge en rien du
fait d'arriver à trouver un accord nous
sommes désireux d'ouvrir les discussions
et à ce moment là
évidemment comme nous allions entrer en
discussion j'en ai prévenu les pouvoirs
publics comme c'est mon rôle est ma
responsabilité
alors ensuite vous avez une deuxième
partie de questions qui vont mesurer
bien travers ce que je vous dis que tout
cela était à la fois non nécessaires
puisque nous n'avions pas besoin très
préliminaire puisque ça les discussions
ont commencé et que par nature à titre
personnel puisque j'avais la
responsabilité de donner évidemment
mon avis pour l'ensemble des parties
prenantes à la fois les actionnaires les
collaborateurs et l'ensemble de
l'écosystème français
je n'avais pas d'avis à ce moment là
nous nous entrions en discussion à ce
moment là il ya eu l'intervention que
que vous connaissez du du ministre des
finances bruno le maire qui a estimé que
je vais
essayez d'être fidèle à ce qu'il a dit
que dans le contexte du moment compte
tenu du rôle de carrefour et compte tenu
des réflexions souveraineté alimentaire
cette opération n'était pas souhaitable
j'exprime je crois le plus fidèlement
possible la vie qu'il a donné cette
opération donc à ce moment là les
discussions qu'ils allaient s'en sort
qui allait commencer se sont se sont
arrêtés parce que au fond ce n'est pas
une affaire de est ce que le décret sur
la souveraineté permet ou non rentre
peut s'appliquer ou pas c'est que vous
ne faites pas une opération avec le
premier employeur français est un acteur
étranger dont vous estimez que les
pouvoirs publics n'y sont pas favorables
pour moi ce n'était pas une affaire
juridique d'une affaire de contexte et
donc nous avons décidé de mettre fin aux
discussions qui allait commencer voilà
la manière dont ça s'est passé
qu'est-ce que j'en tire comme comme
conclusion d'abord que nous allions bien
avant cette opération et nous allons
bien après cette opération
encore une fois je n'étais pas dans une
situation je me disais mon dieu il nous
faut absolument une opération
deuxièmement évidemment contrairement à
ce que j'ai pu lire nous ne sommes pas
dans un contexte où je me dis tout ça
doit rester un peu discret jusqu'à
septembre post élection présidentielle
celui qui connaît le contexte post
élections présidentielles je pense n'est
pas dans cette salle est pas dans notre
pays
et puis en septembre 2022 on rediscutera
naturellement cette opération a été
présenté elle ne sait finalement elle
n'a pas avancé et elle est derrière nous
je ne suis pas encore une fois en
recherche d'une opération et il ya plein
d'autres façon pour nous de nous de
développer une manière très très
offensive
la grande question de la souveraineté
alimentaire qui a été évoquée je
voudrais vous donner un élément de
contexte qui je crois est intéressant
nous sommes le premier acteur au brésil
ont fait 22 % du parc de parts de marché
aux oiseaux à tous les types de magasins
au brésil
des caches entre carrie sous une
enseigne s'appelle atacadao aux
hypermarchés de la proximité tous les
opérateurs et au brésil parce que c'est
un pays de 120 millions d habitants avec
les difficultés que vous connaissez mais
on a un rôle très fort j'ai décidé de
vous en arrivez que je voulais qu'on
soit leader et qu'on soit un leader très
puissance que nous ne sommes pas en
france
la particularité de carrefour par
rapport à ses grands concurrents
mondiaux c'est que nous ne sommes pas un
grand leader en france et donc nous
devions être un grand leader au brésil
et on a beaucoup travaillé on s'est
beaucoup développée on a beaucoup ouvert
deux magasins on a bien travaillé
à telle enseigne qu'on a on a identifié
retrouver en situation en mars avril de
l'année dernière de pouvoir faire une
opération de dents en février de cette
année de pouvoir faire une opération de
consolidation au brésil en a acheté un
concurrent qui fait 10% de part de
marché le gouvernement brésilien je me
suis dit je dois dire mais on avait un
petit peu informé le gouvernement aurait
signé avant dont vous connaissez en plus
les spécificités je me suis dit
heureusement que ce gouvernement
brésilien ne nous a pas rétorquer
souveraineté alimentaire je ne vous ne
pouvait pas la france ne peut pas se
développer au brésil etc
parce qu'au fond c'est l'avenir d'une
partie de carrefour et son développement
international qui en aura été qui en
auraient été affaibli on a pu faire
cette opération en brésil on va
évidemment passer devant les autorités
de concurrence et j'espère qu'on ça nous
permettra d'avoir un très bel actif au
brésil est de nous développer très
fortement
donc nous sommes aujourd'hui cette
opération est derrière nous c'est un
c'est un épisode
on apprend toujours de tous les épisodes
et on a ainsi peut-être mieux découvert
le rôle central de carrefour dans la
souveraineté française est pour moi la
souveraineté c'était des industries un
peu différente mais je prends acte du
fait que nous sommes une industrie de
souveraineté et nous avons un rôle dans
la souveraineté alimentaire et
heureusement nous allons bien donc on va
pouvoir se développer et continuer à
faire des acquisitions dans d'autres
géographies pour pour porter haut le
drapeau français et qui a toujours été
vous le savez un élément fort de notre
histoire voilà pour vous alors pourquoi
je tard j'espère avoir répondu à vos
interrogations sur cette question si
vous me permettez donc bien sûr les
suggestions
s'il ya un point que j'ai pas et
complémentaires dans cette affaire vous
aviez dans les premières discussions
avec couche-tard vraiment très en amont
décider
d'un certain nombre de questions
d'autonomie mais aussi de projets et
notamment vous nous avez dit
d'investissement ça veut dire que
couche-tard étaient prêts à mettre des
investissements est notamment très de
façon très importante d'après ce que
j'ai lu dans le parc de magasins
français est-ce que ça cet
investissement là ne va pas vous manquer
même si vous allez bien écouter aucun
chef d'entreprise ne va se présenter
devant vous en disant que si on lui
donne des moyens supplémentaires pour
investir dans son outil de travail c'est
une mauvaise nouvelle donc en effet le
gros couche-tard avait décidé d'
investir puissamment dans notre parc de
magasins
est-ce que je peux investir sans la
réponse est oui
ça veut dire que j'investisse page
investit pas à votre endroit et que
j'investis pas au même rythme ça c'était
donc un des éléments d'intérêt si cette
opération avait avancé mais fort
heureusement on n'est pas dans la
situation où on se dit parce qu'on a une
capacité à bien mener nos opérations on
est capable d'investir dans notre parc
de magasins il se développer sans l'aide
de couche-tard pour synthétiser ma
réponse sur ce point pour couche tard on
considère qu'en juste une petite
remarque c'est bien c'est beau tout
petit c'est bruno le maire qui a décidé
points c'est ce que vous ne nuire il est
ministre des finances mais il aimait de
l'économie pardon et et
il a estimé dans le cadre de resto c'est
de ses responsabilités que cette
opération donnerait un problème de
souveraineté alimentaire
par contre qu exposer le roi de fer au
brésil on peut pas le faire reprendre
sur les mers situe exactement la
tradition et on n'a rien compris sujets
suivants peut-être le gérer le parc de
magasins parce que j'ai eu plusieurs
types de questions liées aux oraux au
magasin sous sous sous toutes ses formes
vous avez raison de me les poser à moi
au fond parce que vous avez en face de
vous le seul acteur je vais dire mondial
à avoir tous les formats de magasins en
général d'un groupe de distribution vaud
l'un d'eux vous évoquez à raison lidl
tout à l'heure c'est quelqu'un qui
maîtrise bien format qu'ils opèrent tous
qui opère toujours le même type de
format et on est un des seuls acteurs
voire le seul acteur à avoir
l'intégralité des formats de magasins
nausées quelqu'un qui sait ce qu'est un
hypermarché du cash and carry du format
de proximité en zone rurale
la vision qui est la mienne c'est que
chacun de ces formats là a du potentiel
et un avenir contrairement à aux
analystes que je lis souvent je ne
considère pas par exemple que
l'hypermarché n'a pas d'avenir
moi je considère que l'hypermarché
répond à une attente très précise de nos
clients une promesse large
le prix le plus bas et une présence
extrêmement complète d'une offre
alimentaire avec des produits frais de
produits de grande consommation d'une
offre d'un alimentaire de services de
e-commerce puisque on développe de plus
en plus souvent à l'intérieur de nos
hypermarchés débarque store donc
l'hypermarché est en train de se
transformer d'ailleurs ces performances
sont bien
meilleur c'est un c'est un modèle
d'avenir et c'est une très bonne
nouvelle pour nous tous parce que c'est
là que se concentrent les emplois les
débouchés pour l'agriculture dans notre
métier de manière les plus significatifs
puisque c'est c'est le coeur du modèle
français 50% de la distribution en
france se fait toujours dans les
hypermarchés
donc quand je lis de temps en temps les
hypermarchés n'ont pas d'avenir à viser
très bien il y aura des magasins de
proximité
oui il ya quand même plusieurs centaines
de milliers de collaborateurs qui
travaillent dedans il ya des emplois
débouchés indirects qui sont extrêmement
importants il ya un travail très très
précis qui est fait avec les producteurs
autour
bref quand l'hypermarché va mieux c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour l'ensemble de la
collectivité et on est en train de
transformer l'hypermarché en en faisant
à la fois un magasin un lieu de service
et un lieu beaucoup plus relié au
e-commerce la proximité vous m'avez un
plusieurs d'entre vous m'ont interrogé
sur cette question
quand on a présenté le plan carrefour
2022 c'est en septembre 2010 8,1 qu'on a
présenté car pour lille 1 2 c'est pas
cette année pour l'année prochaine parce
que là je serai un peu présomptueux
c'était en 2018 exactement c'est pour ça
que c'est de la faim et demain matin on
avait annoncé l'ouverture de trois mille
magasins de proximité
parce qu'évidemment je crois aux
magasins de proximité parce
qu'évidemment il ya aujourd'hui à la
fois dans les grands les grandes
métropoles urbaines mais aussi dans les
plus petites villes et dans les zones
rurales un très fort potentiel des
magasins de proximité bien opérer avec
un assortiment réduit un assortiment
locale et le modèle de la franchise est
donc ce modèle là on l'a beaucoup
développé je vous disais qu'on avait
ouvert 600 magasins dans les trois
dernières années en france
on va continuer à accélérer pour
répondre à votre votre question on va
ouvrir on ouvre des magasins à la fois
en zone urbaine très urbaine à paris et
dans les grandes métropoles françaises
mais aussi en zone rurale à travers
notamment
l'enseigne que certains d'entre vous
connaissez bien qu'ils aient carrefour
contact qui est moquée pour nous un
élément de développement et
d'aménagement du territoire d'eau que
hypermarchés proximité et entre les deux
tous les formats de magasins que vous
connaissez le supermarché et c est ce
qui est très intéressant dans le modèle
que nous sommes en train de construire
et l'un d'entre vous m'interrogez tout à
fait à raison sur la complexité
logistique de ce que nous avions à
opérer c'est que ce modèle il n'a de
sens il suffit pas de dire j'ai tous ces
formats je deviens omni canal
j'ai tous ces formats je deviens owni
canal si je parviens à les relier entre
les relier entre eux ça veut dire les
relier entre sur les flux ça veut dire
les relier entre eux pour le client être
relié pour le client ça veut dire qu'un
client a un avantage quand il est quand
il reste à l'intérieur pardon du terme
un peu barbare de l'écosystème carrefour
ça veut dire qu'ils cumulent des points
qu'ils cumulent des promotions qu'ils
cumulent des fidélités qu'il cumule des
abonnements et quand vous arrivez à
mener à construire ce modèle ovni canal
où vous vous reliez vous articuler la
distribution physique et digital l'homme
dit canal a énormément de poids mais
monsieur le sénateur vous posiez tout à
fait raison la question vous mesurez la
transformation logistique que ça que ça
signifie nous avions un modèle qu'on
construit mes prédécesseurs qui était
merveilleux
ce modèle un entrepôt qu'il y ait des
grands volumes vers l'hypermarché qui
était très efficient très efficace et
aujourd'hui c'est une série de flux
logistiques différents à construire
jusqu'à la livraison à domicile on a
conduit on aura conduit des plans
d'économies entre 2018 et est
aujourd'hui qui auront fait économiser à
notre groupe un peu plus de 4 milliards
d'euros entre 2018 et et 2023
d'abord je vais vous dire pourquoi et
après je vais vous dire s'ils vont me
l'autorisé comment pourquoi ces
économies de coûts vous mesurer à
travers tout ce que je vous ai dit
l'immensité des investissements qui font
que nos groupes réaliste on n'est plus
dans un modèle quel modèle que nous
avons tous bien connus des magasins le
seul à seul chose que nous avions à
faire c'était d'investir régulièrement
dans le magasin etc
on est devenu un vrai acteur industriel
et on investit dans la logistique
on investit dans les schémas industriels
en investissent dans ce qu'on appelle la
donne et la data on a investi dans
toutes nos géographies et qui ont
investi évidemment dans nos magasins
pour les rendre plus attractif c'est
donc on a les investissements massifs a
mené à la fois sur notre modèle owni
canal mais aussi sur nos prix puisque
nous avions un retard par rapport à nos
concurrents qui sont ceux qui font les
prix en france ceux qui font les prix en
france c'est principalement le
groupement d'indépendants leclerc on
avait un décalage de compétitivité prix
contrairement à ce que ce que je lis
parfois c'est évidemment pas carrefour
qui fixe le prix puisque nous sommes
plus cher aujourd'hui que carrefour
même si on a réduit ce décalage donc
vous m'avez compris on avait besoin
d'eux on a besoin d'économiser dans
beaucoup de structures dont beaucoup
d'organisation dans nos processus pour 1
ce tir pour construire le modèle de
demain si on ne fait pas ça si on
n'avait pas fait ça le groupe aurait eu
un problème de pérennité à perdre mais
on le fait et je crois qu on le fait de
manière assez performante
l'immense majorité de ces économies là
ne sont pas faits par des plans
d'économies de personnel on avait fait
vous l'avez vu sans doute au début les
plans d'économies sur nos sièges parce
qu'on avait des sièges de très grosse
taille beaucoup plus gros que nos
concurrents on avait un siège de près de
dix mille personnes en france c'est des
économies de renégociations avec
l'ensemble de nos prestataires ce qu'ils
nous fournissent l'électricité dans le
monde nos prestataires technologiques
les sociétés de nettoyage des sociétés
de gardiennage et puis l'amélioration de
nos propres organisations de nos propres
processus de fonctionnement c'est tout
ça qui nourrit les plans les plans
d'économies qui nous permettent
d'investir dans l'outil de travail
j'en viens à la question à monsieur le
sénateur merci de l'avoir posée je la
prends comme une question pour moi très
importante du modèle social au fond et
je ne me dérobe pas à l'autre partie de
votre question quel modèle social mais
partage de la richesse
je vais évoquer très rapidement enfin je
vais voter mon cas et puis évidemment
surtout vous répondra deuxième partie de
votre question vous avez raison un jour
n'est pleinement conscience un patron
d'un groupe du cac40 ça gagne très bien
sa vie je gagne très bien ma vie
edit je gagne un million cinq de salaire
fixe parents et j'ai ensuite des
mécanismes de rémunération variable qui
sont assis sur l'obtention ou non de
d'objectifs si je les atteint pas
rémunération augmente si je les atteint
pas ce qui arrive certaines années la
rémunération reste autour des
rémunérations fixes et donc ça peut
aller jusqu'aux montants vous avez dit
165% de ma rémunération fixe est indices
et sur des objectifs économiques
c'est le chiffre d'affaires le résultat
opérationnel de ce qu'on appelle le free
cash flow la rse etc etc
c'est ça le modèle et c'est une
rémunération évidemment dont j'ai
conscience sinon amélioration très
substantiel après je voudrais vous dire
un mot du du modèle social de carrefour
d'abord évidemment je parle également
avec mes salariés qui me parlent sans
filtre dans l'ensemble on ne parle son
filtre donc c'est très bien et je sais
combien ce notre métier est un métier
qui est difficile qui est un métier il
faut faire au quotidien que ce soit dans
les centres logistiques ce soit quand
vous êtes caissier ce soit quand vous
mettiez les magasins en rayon et avec
des situations personnelles qui sont des
situations personnelles évidemment
souvent difficile mais le modèle social
de carrefour je le dis d'autant plus
volontiers que je n'en suis pas là non
plus les initiateurs j'aimerais en est
l'initiateur mais ce n'est pas le cas
c'est un modèle qui est un modèle qui
est plus protecteur pardon de le dire
que nos concurrents et ça évidemment les
chiffres le disent très bien
je voudrais vous évoquez quelques points
dans l'ensemble si je regarde la grille
des salaires de nos métiers et la grille
de carrefour de la grille des salaires
de carrefour et 10% supérieur à nos
salaires de la branche 10%
donc nos collaborateurs sont payés sur
14 mois là où notre branche c'est sur 13
mois il ya des dispositifs de protection
sur le plan social sur le plan des
mutuelles sur plan des pros prévoyance
qui sont beaucoup plus avantageuses il
ya des mécanismes de participation et
d'intéressement qui atteignent en gros
1300 euros par an quand augmenté de 15%
sur les deux dernières années qu'ils
sont uniques dans notre secteur qui sont
six fois les minimums légaux qui font
partie du modèle que on a construit
qu'on continue et moi j'étais très
heureux l'année dernière cette année je
vous donne un exemple de me l'année
dernière et cette année l'année dernière
contrairement là par contre je peux pas
vous laisser dire ça parce que ce n'est
pas vrai nous sommes le seul acteur qui
a pris une décision extraordinairement
forte et je tiens tous les éléments à
votre disposition monsieur le sénateur
attendait la jeune si vous me permettez
aux papas du ccer je vais vous parler de
la prime parce que c'est un élément
important
on l'a versé une prime de 1000 euros
nets pour tous ceux qui étaient sur le
terrain tous ceux et pas proratisé
autant de travail et j'étais fier et
j'étais nan nan franchement non non
c'est pas plus qu'aux plus mais je vais
vous présenterons je vous présenterai
les éléments vous savez il ya un élément
très simple pour le voir moi je publie
ces chiffres
je suis une société cotée donc j'ai une
ligne prime 1000 euros elle m'a coûté
l'année dernière et j'en suis fier 85
millions d'euros
donc vous comprenez bien quand vous
rapporter ça au nombre de personnes que
ceux qui sont sur le terrain que toutes
les personnes qui sont sur le terrain
l'année dernière ont touché une prime de
1000 euros
deuxième chose cette année intéresse
vous vous dites blocage des salaires
n'ont évidemment maintenant il n'y a pas
de blocage des salaires
il ya une augmentation elle n'est pas
très importante à vous avez raison mais
il ya une augmentation
il ya une nouvelle prime qui n'est pas
de mon temps et puis à l'augmentation de
la participation ce que je veux vous
dire le sénateur je partage pleinement
et je comprends parfaitement votre
interrogation sur le sur l' équilibre
c'est une bonne interrogations en
revanche on ne peut pas dire du modèle
carrefour et je le dis d'autant plus
volontiers c'est pas moi qui les
construit dans le temps on essaye de le
continuer mais le modèle social de
carrefour c'est un modèle pour la grande
distribution qui est un modèle qui est
plus avantageux et plus protecteurs
après je peux comprendre que vous
une vision différente des grands
équilibres mais je veux juste dire ça
sur carrefour s'il vomit autorisé parce
que c'est un élément important
je vous propose qu'on parle bien sûr
mais vous avez dit une chose importante
à chaque fois qu on a un grand chef
d'entreprise vivement modèle social et
le meilleur par rapport à mes
concurrents donc on a mis sur le cléac'h
ou d'autres nouvelles nous dira la même
chose mais vous avez là où on peut avoir
un petit débat c'est vous dites sur le
modèle social dans la grande
distribution et dans la grande
distribution
je vous le dis le modèle social est très
faible et met en difficulté des milliers
de salariés
quand on a du chu du du temps partiel
imposé et à une rémunération juste au
dessus du smic ou au smic quand on a 24
heures 880 euros par mois ça c'est pas
gelé vue
moi aussi je tiens de ses éléments à
votre disposition si vous voulez
monsieur le président directeur général
là on a un problème parce que ces deux
sont des métiers et vous le savez
extrêmement difficile et donc la
rémunération des salariés et pose
question quand l'année dernière et je
finis ils voient 6 ou 7 % de plus de
chiffre d'affaires 78 milliards d'euros
alors évidemment vous avez venir le
chiffre d'affaires ça va induire
complexe que ça d'accord et qui voit les
rémunération des grands dirigeants et
donc je n'ai pas que vous ces grands
dirigeants et hauts sur le terrain et un
petit débat quand même voila voila c'est
tout simplement le comprends je vais
merci vais pas rebondir pour mais merci
de
cependant au monde agricole et à la
grande distribution
je sais que je ne vais pas être
populaire mais comment se parlent très
très très franchement je vais vous dire
les choses telles que je les je les
ressens nous ne sommes pas nous n'avons
jamais été et nous n'avons aucun intérêt
à être l'ennemi du monde agricole et
pardon ce n'est pas le cas ce n'est pas
le cas ni pour moi j'allais dire ni pour
mes principaux les principaux
concurrents on est le premier débouché
du monde agricole
je travaille avec des milliers de pme
avec lesquels nous signons nos accords
dès le mois de janvier et ses désaccords
en croissance
nous travaillons depuis et là non plus
ce n'est pas moi qui ai mis en place le
système ce formidable mécanisme des
filières qualité carrefour nous
travaillons avec vingt mille producteurs
sur un mécanisme qui est un mécanisme
pluriannuel où vous avez tout à fait
raison
nous nous mettons d'accord sur des prix
des volumes des clauses de revoyure
pluriannuel et où nous avons développé à
travers ces filières qualité carrefour
sont un formidable héritage de
l'enseignent une proximité un travail en
commun avec le producteur qui est je
crois exemplaires je voudrais revenir
sur la loi égalise je ne vais pas
initier la loi et galim puisque je suis
arrivé
son texte était stabilisé vous comprenez
à travers ce que je vous dis que n'étant
pas tout à fait convaincu qu'une énième
loi était indispensable
je ne les ai pas pousser j'ai considéré
qu'elle était qu'elle était dans mon
nouvel espace normatif et j'estimais
d'ailleurs qu'elle était positif puisque
pour bon nombre de ces dispositions
elle reprenait des éléments de ce que
nous faisons depuis longtemps les
filières que j'ai évoqué les contrats
pluriannuels les contrats de conversion
au bio qui nous permettent de garantir
un volume et un prix aux agriculteurs
qui sont en transe 30 transformer leurs
terres et une attention aux matières
premières agricoles qui nous ont conduit
d'ailleurs et je tiens vraiment ces
éléments à votre disposition et
d'ailleurs ils sont publics a revalorisé
par exemple prix du lait de 10 % au
cours des deux dernières années et avoir
cette idée que les matières premières
devraient augmenter après monsieur
center vous avez posé un élément sur
lequel je vais me permettre de vous
apporter une petite contradiction non
nous n'avons pas touché 1 milliards
d'euros si vous avions touché 1 milliard
d'euros je parle collectivement je
prends pas pour carrefour si c'est en
partant ils ont atteint 601 milliards
voilà si si je les avais touché qu'est
ce qui se serait passé
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'avait dit mon
confrère michel edouard leclerc qui
s'était trompé il se serait passé de
l'inflation il y aura eu de l'inflation
les prix auraient augmenté sa va dire
que j'ai pris de la marge à les prix
auraient augmenté et on en rêve une
inflation
qu'est ce qu'on a vu d'ailleurs je
l'avais dit au moment de la loi zéro
inflation pourquoi parce qu'il ya une
péréquation entre nos rayons donc vous
avez raison il y à des prix qui ont
augmenté la votre chiffre est bon il ya
un certain nombre de progrès qui était
sous lé seuil de revente à perte qui ont
augmenté mais on a baissé les prix parce
qu'on est dans un univers extrêmement
concurrence sur nos marques propres ou
sur d'autres catégories de produits qui
n'étaient pas concernés par le srpj ce
qu'on appelle de la péréquation c'est
pour c'est la raison pour laquelle il ya
un élément qui s'impose à nous tous
c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'inflation dans
le
le mécanisme on peut d'ailleurs se poser
la question si l'impression sera utile
mais comme c'est un secteur très
concurrentiel normalement le mois de
janvier exactement mis en examen mais
comme il ya eu comme il ya eu des
baisses de prix sur d'autres catégories
trop dur pour être compétitif voyez vous
parliez lidl quand vous voulez être
compétitif face à lidl qu'à la marque
propre la plus basse
vous baissez votre marque propre ou
baisser le prix de votre marque le prof
est donc la résultante vraiment celle là
elle s'impose à nous c'est qu'il y a pas
d'inflation
donc en effet il y aurait eu un
ruissellement très très fort s'il ya eu
aucune péréquation et medion qui a eu
des péréquation entre les ans entre les
secteurs et cet élément là il est
extrêmement important a observé sur les
négociations et sur les gars l'hymne et
galim de bon je vais pas revenir à mon
propos sur sur l'agriculture sur les
normes parce que vous avez compris que
j'ai un petit doute sur faut-il aussi
souvent légiférer sur cette question là
dont le rapport papin il ya des choses
très importantes que je demande de
pardon aussi le sénateur je vais vous
contredire une deuxième fois
moi je ne vois pas pourquoi je j'en suis
sûr mais je prends mon risque
je ne vois pas pourquoi vraiment je ne
vois pas pourquoi il n'y a pas une
transparence sur les prix moi quand je
revalorise le prix que je verse à
lactalis et à danone
je veux savoir ce que ce qu'obtient
l'agriculteur je suis en le droit de
savoir et la représentation nationale
aussi parce que quand je remonte de 10%
le prix du lait
quand je remonte le prix de la viande
bovine et que j'appelle les agriculteurs
mais notre et que je leur dis qu'est ce
qui s'est passé et qu'il me dise à rien
et qu'ils sont furieux parce que il n'y
a rien et qu'ils ont l'impression de
s'être fait avoir
parce que il y à rien je me dis
je ne mets pas en cause les industries
agroalimentaires parce que il y en a
d'autres qui interviennent d'ailleurs il
ya des transporteurs etc
il ya d'autres acteurs je me dis que
l'argent est passé entre les deux et
donc je ne vois pas ce qu'ils s'opposent
et c'est ce qui est très intéressant
dans le rapport papin et que je demande
à cor et à cri depuis le début de la loi
égalise
carrefour a payé star et l'agriculteur
il a touché sa et au fond je n'ai
toujours pas compris mais mais mais sans
doute le projet de loi sur lequel vous
allez beaucoup de travail et permettra
de le préciser en quoi nous avons besoin
d'une nouvelle réforme on croit la
nouvelle réforme va le permettre parce
que la seule question c'est la
transparence de ce que nous faisons moi
je veux bien qu'on me fasse des
reproches et franchement il ya des
domaines il ya des filières et sait où
on a des négocier sur où parfois on part
trop dur etc et j'en conviens je veux
bien voir ses reproches si je sais que
quand on augmente
l'exploitant agricole à la somme et vous
avez vous avez tout à fait raison
si l'industriel fait un magnifique
travail entre les deux on aura tous la
compréhension de ce travail moi j'ai dû
laisser ce sont mes partenaires
l'industrie agroalimentaire dont je je
je je comprends que sur un certain
nombre de produits parce qu'ils innovent
il décide qu'une petite partie de ce que
je verse en plus ils le prennent eux
mais je crois qu'on a un besoin absolu
de compréhension de la transparence de
la marge et si je peux me permettre de
vous faire une demande à mon tour dans
le projet qui vous sera soumis plus tôt
que la fixité de la matière première qui
pardon
avec les petits souvenirs d'économies
que j'ai jamais totalement considérer
que le contrôle des prix ou les prix
administrés ou les prix bloqués sur
longue tendance c'était intenable sur
longue tendance je ne vois pas surtout
dans une danse dans une matière aussi
vivante que la matière agricole
qu'est ce qu'on fera si les cours se met
à dériver dans tous les sens à la baisse
comme à la hausse
et quand on a fixé le prix au milieu jeu
franchement je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
fixer de manière pluriannuelle les prix
et donc plutôt que cette question là la
question centrale c'est comment est-ce
qu'on impose à tous les acteurs la
pluriannualité la fixité il a et la
transparence
et franchement j'y suis prêt et je
devrais pas gagner à tous les coups
quelquefois vous viendrez me dire
attendez on nous avait dit ça mais
franchement là dessus vous n'êtes pas au
rendez vous on n'est pas au rendez vous
parce que vous disiez vous aviez faire
2% sa effet à 1,6 mais on verra ses prix
je vous assure que c'est
extraordinairement frustrant on a fait
beaucoup d'efforts quand je dis nous
c'est aussi le monde de la grande
distribution pour revaloriser beaucoup
des filières il ya eu c'est pour ça que
je ne considère pas que la loi et galim
soi n'est pas des éléments positifs
parce que deux dents il y avait quand
même s'est prise de conscience dont on
avait bien besoin des uns et les autres
de la revalorisation du prix de la
matière première et je pense que
l'esprit de la loi et galim a quand même
apporté quelque chose et donc il ya eu
il ya eu des choses qui ont été faites
soyez des états généraux y ait des
choses qui ont été faites qui sont
significatives qui sont financés par les
distributeurs
je ne vois pas leurs traductions
aujourd'hui au bout de la chaîne parce
qu'on ne sait pas ce qui revient aux
différents acteurs vous m'avez compris
sur ce sujet mais je crois que c'est un
sujet important
il est d'autant plus important pardon je
n'ai pas répondu à la question sur le
poids des producteurs locaux
dans notre métier peut-être ça sera une
de mes conclusions
au fond c'est le consommateur qui
choisit et si vous aviez un doute sur
finalement sauvé là il nous dit qu'il va
développer les productions locales
les productions françaises il nous dit
qu'il fait 95 % de fruits et légumes
français etc
je le fais pas parce que je les décider
ou parce que je le veux ou parce que je
pense que c'est dire je le fais parce
que le consommateur on me le demande et
les consommateurs alors ça tombe bien
c'est ce que je pense aussi mais mais
les consommateurs ils nous demandent des
produits locaux voyez on s'est rendu
compte d'un élément est vous qui
connaissez par coeur le monde de
l'agriculture
ça vous sera très très familier on s'est
rendu compte qu'un des problèmes
principale qu'on avait avec les nouveaux
producteurs éleveurs qui veulent
travailler avec nous les petits pmc la
complexité administrative de nos
entreprises
il fallait qu'ils viennent il fallait
des mois pour être référencé des
contrats de douze pages des mondes et
des semaines pour être payé et quand on
est un éleveur un producteur on n'a pas
le temps de faire tout cela et donc on a
lancé cette initiative que j'appelais
kilomètre zéro en disant vous venez dans
le magasin c'est un contrat qui tient en
une page et demie qui est très simple et
vous êtes payés au bout de huit jours et
ça a fait un appel d'air frais de
nouveaux producteurs éleveurs qui est
qui qui nous ont rejoints voilà ce que
je voulais vous dire pour finir
là-dessus sur le monde agricole et c'est
pas on a besoin d'une agriculture
puissante
nous on a vraiment besoin d'une
agriculture france puissante mois ci
l'agriculture française
quand l'agriculture française va mal et
j'ai je connais la situation
individuelle de beaucoup d'agriculteurs
c'est un énorme problème pour carrefour
c'est un énorme problème parce qu'on a
besoin de développer des produits locaux
j'écoutais l'autre jour la présidente de
la fnsea qui disait de manière très
pertinente
il ya un problème de compétitivité
globale que vous connaissez les normes
sanitaires au coût du travail aux normes
environnementales etc et on a besoin
d'une agriculture puissant personne n'a
plus besoin d'une agriculture qui va
bien et d'agriculteurs qui vont bien que
la grande distribution ces 20%
aujourd'hui de mon activité
on travaille les pme représentent 50% de
la croissance est un produit sur trois
dans les magasins donc j'ai besoin que
les pme le monde agricole à y bien j'en
prends ma part je ne fais pas assez il
ya plein de choses qui vont pas assez
vite
il ya des négociations qui sont trop
durs l'un d'entre vous évoquez à raison
un monde des négociations mais qui sont
aussi liées à ces négociations annuelles
à ce rite des négociations où il ya des
choses qui ne sont pas acceptables on
travaille beaucoup à faire des
formations à bâtir des chars pour que
les négociations là on parle
principalement des négociations et les
grands industriels mais se passe de
manière normalisée donc il ya encore
plein de choses à changer dans notre
univers et dans l'univers de la grande
distribution mais il ya il ya une chose
dont je voudrais vraiment vous
convaincre on ne veut pas et on ne
pourrait pas faire sans une agriculture
française puissante et moi ce que je
cherche et je cherche notamment à
travers la transparence est pas une
nouvelle norme que tout le monde va
travailler à regarder comment appliquer
ou moins bien appliqué c'est qu'on aille
très vite vers la seule question qui est
aujourd'hui 130 sur toutes les filières
agricoles
comment est ce qu'on arrive à avoir
d'informations sûr qui paye quoi à qui
et celle-là je crois qu'elle est
vraiment importante pour qu'on ait un
modèle agro alimentaire et une
souveraineté alimentaire qui soit bien
assurée
[Musique]